in less than a week life in the small
town of castle poster lingo has
completely changed the corona virus
outbreak in northern Italy's Lombardy
region is what did it
forcing checkpoints to go up and keeping
residents from getting out
since we're barred from accessing areas
under quarantine we speak to volunteer
medic Marco fregoli on skype he worries
about what will happen next but also
tries to stay calm I don't live alone so
every time I go back home I think about
it because maybe I've been in contact
with someone that has it but I'm without
symptoms and we're constantly checked
Marco says he doesn't want to diminish
the gravity of the crisis but he also
likes looking on the bright Sun and
tells us there are surprising benefits
to living under lockdown it's beautiful
because you see kids playing in the
streets the way it was many years ago
during the days of our parents and
grandparents
there was much more light heartedness
just up the road from castle booster
lingo is the town of Catania considered
the center of the outbreak because the
first locally transmitted coronavirus
case was detected there mario parati
runs a residential facility for patients
with mental and physical disabilities he
tells a staff at the center are doing
all they can to keep the situation calm
and to ensure the compound remains free
of the virus the residents understand
this is a special situation and they've
adapted to it without getting too
anxious even our patients who fall along
the autism spectrum and who usually have
the most difficult time accepting
changes to their routines they have
accepted that this is an unusual
situation here in the regional capital
an hour's drive away the anxiety is also
evident as public spaces remain far
quieter than usual for days Italian
government officials have been urging
citizens not to panic the people under
quarantine we've been speaking to our
heating that advice as coronavirus cases
in the country continue to rise they
find themselves growing more concerned
but they say they're doing their utmost
to remain calm how much improvement is
theater Milan